it's coming along dude it's hodgepodge
nice man you get some
uh some plants in there and [ __ ] you're
talking about some plants we got
we just got a grow lamp in today we
found a 30 grow lamp on amazon
and uh so we got to get these a couple
of porthos ferns you know
why because man we want to get the we
want to get um just a little bit more
foliage in there
we're running on that we're trying to
get a little bit more nature in there i
like that
yeah greening up a little bit yeah we're
trying to get like a little bit of ivy
you know have kind of like an iv kind of
that's where you walk in and that's cool
it's just going to take a while yeah
it's cool vibe let's import those plants
right there i think what do they got
there
how much those run 17 17 bucks but
here's the thing they're small you have
to [ __ ] raise them
uh and then you got to put that light on
them why don't you grow a little
marijuana in there i'll grow some wheat
in there if we can get somebody that
knows more about it
yeah i wouldn't mind growing a little
bit of weed maybe sending that some of
the fans
yeah selling it it's not a bad idea the
feel strength
that strain boy makes you just
it'll cure down syndrome bro i beat it
how you beat it there's a lot of rumors
in my town that i beat down syndrome
really yeah well that's inspiring man
that's how i felt when i heard them
because i didn't start them
and that's one of the things that's
beautiful about sometimes being in a
small town is
you know it doesn't take long for you to
hear [ __ ] about yourself it doesn't
right yeah you get more feedback yeah in
l.a some guy walks right by you in the
hall like oh look at this [ __ ]
chimpanzee you know but you never know
you never hear it but in a small town's
only nine people
you know you hear it now though these
days social media yeah
they'll get you you get a lot of haters
on there uh i'm sure
i'm sure i don't see a lot of it but i'm
sure do you um
i don't think so i mean i get i get some
stuff i guess
but i don't think anything i really i'm
trying to think of something tough to
hate on you
because you're not really like i'll get
like i'll get some hate obviously
one of my you're easier to hate well you
think i mean there's just more i mean
not in like a
if i know you know but if i don't see
you dude walking by
more more than you oh dude i'm like
who's this
well you look like a mechanic from
nordstrom rack dude
that's the [ __ ] problem you're like
damn i didn't know
uh nordstrom rack did tires you know
this dude looked like a [ __ ] yeah
you look like you're an extra from water
boy
oh god dude you look bro bro
you got to get a better mirror man maybe
i'm [ __ ] cheap mirrors dude
you don't have the same mirror if you
you and i walked down the street
and people focused on me bro
you have a moment and i celebrated
no you look bro you let me think about
exactly what you look like dude
gee bro you look like
dude you look like somebody that drinks
keels at the airport dude you look like
a troubled man
you look like you just drink small
bottles of kiehl's hand lotion at the
airport
you got issues man you need to start
seeing it i need a new mirror brother
bro you need a sketch artist chin can't
draw something
you can't mock up a decent image of this
man dude
this guy looks like joe you look like uh
lenny from of mice and men but if we're
filmed in like um
like if it were filmed probably more
film than the great gatsby is sacramento
you look like the biggest [ __ ] kid
in sacramento
bro and that's true dude and i mean that
and i don't mean that in a mean way
no i feel you man you're the one that
beat down syndrome
but that's not saying much look at you
right there lenny small right there bruh
you look like straight up lenny small
dude switching this jacket
dude you look like you're like the dude
who if everybody's escaping prison you'd
be like nah i gotta
i gotta be up in the morning for
breakfast you know saying like you get
to do this like
doesn't get that everybody's [ __ ]
getting out you know
oh okay guys oh have fun in here
[Laughter]
you gotta reboot man oh you you
i probably do when you see my back
ripple and i pull myself
up like a champ like a chimp 30 times
while talking to you why wouldn't i give
that to you
it's a gift it's a gift it's a gift